[Musique]
alors stéphanie aujourd'hui je te
présente la vierge rouge qui est
l'histoire de louise michel donc un peu
en résonance avec le 14 juillet
devillard donc là c'est sûr l'histoire
parisienne aussi cette fois-ci de la
commune en 1871 quand le peuple c'est
s'est élevé contre les prussiens et on
va ici
et contre les versaillais et donc là on
a un très très beau roman graphique de
vyver habituellement vibert fecteau des
ouvrages universitaires et là ils nous
ont sorti un très beau roman graphique
tout en noir forcément et tout en rouge
ils ont utilisé uniquement ces deux
couleurs là pour retracer toute la vie
toute l'oeuvre de louise michel donc
dont coupât que appartiennent à la
commune non non elle vient sur leurs
enfants soient vraiment ça situe
vraiment le contexte comment elle s'est
formée comment elle s'agrandit comment
elle a grandi et ensuite donc la commune
ensuite sa nouvelle cadena calédonie où
là elle a pris part echoes fait et cause
pour les kanaks et son retour en france
aussi où elle a finalement toujours
combattu donc voilà c'est l'histoire
d'une combattante qui n'a jamais baissé
les armes et
qui a une vraie influence en plus sur la
vie politique de l'époque donc on voit
ces connexions à victor hugo avec la vie
politique de l'époque et tout ce qu'elle
a pu faire comme donné comme influence
sur son époque il fait que ce soit un
éditeur universitaire c'est pas trop mon
didactique trop scolaire non non ça sur
la commune ou sur la partie fictive an à
l'horizon mais aussi à la fois
pédagogique qui permet un peu de
réussite mais tout ça dans son contexte
et d'avoir un peu d'explications mais le
roman graphique reste un très très beau
roman graphique comme on voit qu'on peut
voir par ailleurs avec une très très
belle pole plume et donc les dessins
sont vraiment là où enfin juste le
dessin suffit en lui-même quoi après
l'histoire est très belle et très bon
très émouvante
effectivement les figures
révolutionnaires
oui et très peu connu finalement donc
voilà dans l'imaginaire ça reste un
icône mais sans plus que s'adresse que
là vraiment on rentre dans les détails
et je trouve ça vraiment passionnant et
en plus très bien à parfum d'un calage
du coup je pense qu'il faut avoir un
petit peu de bagages à une quinzaine
d'années je pense que voilà à partir de
15 ans est tout à fait dévier pour tout
le monde après d'accord voilà bon âge
pour pleurer parce que c'est fait
alors laurent je te présente un petit
livre un derrick byars que j'ai beaucoup
aimée en tout cas pour lesquels je me
suis vraiment bien emballé en fait 14
juillet l'auteur retrace en fait les
événements qu'il a eu avant la prise de
la bastille les émeutes qui a eu et
qu'on oublie un petit peu enfin quand on
se souvient pas toujours depuis la prise
de la bastille et sur la près aussi où
les noms les vêtements non et c'est ça
qui est bien c'est que voilà donc enfin
quand on entend parler de la révolution
on entend robespierre danton et tous les
autres or là non il s'arrête uniquement
à la prise de l'histoire de la prise de
la bastille le 14 juillet 89 c'est tous
les personnages qui ont ce qu'ils se
sont inscrits dans cet événement là et
voilà c'est ça en fait c'est vraiment le
peuple lui même donc c'est très
vivifiant et c'est trés revigorant je
trouve parce qu'en fait au lieu de vol à
s'arrêter aux grands noms que l'on que
l'on qu'on a tous mémorisées c'est au
contraire le petit peuple qui à kaka
fait la révolution donc on a une photo
en fait assez sociologique de qui
étaient là donc c'est des noms et des
prénoms qui dès qu'il énumère en fait
certaines photos de match de mah le tout
à fait une amie en précisant quel métier
c'était donc c'était souvent des gens de
pain qu'ils savaient ni lire ni écrire
mais qui ont eu une grogne terrible et
une fois on vouloir tout changer et on
voit qu'ils ont cette journée du 14
juillet repas jusqu'à bastia jusqu'à la
veste voilà c'est ça les émeutes avant
voisin qui a fait qu'au bout d'un moment
la grogne est montée il y avait vraiment
un plus qu un ras-le-bol envie de
changer vraiment voilà puis et puis
surtout la fin a failli m et
effectivement après de trouver des armes
parce qu'il fallait et des armes et des
munitions les armes étaient à l'arsenal
et munitions étaient à la bastille
d'accord voilà qu'est ce que tu as
trouvé de nouveau dans ce récit a fait
de nouveau parce que effectivement on
oublie que c'est le peuple parisien a
fait quelque part a mené cette
révolution donc moi j'ai vraiment pour
ça ça m'a plu d'accord parce que c'est
vraiment faire honneur au petit peuple
au peuple qui vraiment amener la
révolution et puisque j'ai surtout aimé
c'est qu'il ya cessé
la grogne monte on la sent monter petit
à petit pour exposer au 14 juillet et
finalement faire mon livre je me suis
dit mais on recommence quand c'était
tellement communicatif entre guillemets
la l'emphase qui dit mais et de la
volonté féroce est vraiment comme dans
les tripes qu'ils avaient envie de tout
changer qu'il ya presque quelque chose
de communicatif d'accord donc vraiment
excellent et puis ça on se remémore
aussi finalement qu'est ce que c'était
que ce 14 juillet qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu avant en question
oui c'est ça au travers du fait
historique il ya eu aussi mal de choses
tout à fait un excellent roman motors
juillet les rivières
alors stéphanie je vais te présenter le
régime microbiote d'andré peu sûrs
qu'elle donc ça d'autant qu'on va
recevoir ont plus le 22 octobre prochain
à les libérer donc c'est tout ce qui tu
as sûrement connu le charme discret d'un
test oui oui connu et reconnu voilà it
explique la andré burkel va encore un
petit peu plus loin dans qu'est ce que
le microbiote donc la flore intestinale
sur comment alimenter notre flore
intestinale
quels sont les aliments qui sont bons
pour nos flore intestinale
ceux qui ne sont pas bons comment les
associer à quelle heure
les ingérer enfin voilà d'accord hier de
faire en sorte que la flore intestinale
les aliments soient adaptés à la flore
intestinale de chacun où on a tous la
même flore intestinale
on a pratiquement tous la même flore
intestinale par contre voilà il faut
vraiment se soucier parce que pour bar
qu'elle sait vraiment l'organe principal
de fonctionnement de notre corps donc
pour avoir un corps sain il faut savoir
quand manger comment manger cas les
aliments associés donc tout ça il le
détaille la avec des régimes avec avec
des recettes de retraite a pas de
recettes donc content ouvrage vous dira
uniquement que des recettes là il ya
déjà un petit peu de recettes donc là ça
explique qu est ce que le régime
lui-même qu'est ce que le microbiote
puis elles sont les aliments à éviter
après brésil lesquels à associer
lesquels à privilégier aussi à quelle
heure il faut les ingérer enfin voilà
tout c'est au mas des heures aussi
utiliser savoir parce qu'il faut
associer certains aliments à certaines
heures parce que lafleur intestinale on
a besoin sur ce créneau là laguiole
chocolat à dieu s'est fait sur des
canaux
et pas trop compliqué non plus est ce
que ce grand le match c'est peut-être un
petit peu peur ni microbiote on se
demande bien qu'est ce que c'est oui
mais c'est juste la flore intestinale
voilà c'est vraiment pour essayer de
d'écouter un peu son corps voilà je
pense qu'il faut le prendre comme ça
comme une vraie écoute de son corps et
pour aller vers une centaine un peu plus
elle a tout simplement donc voilà le
régime microbiote a conseillé pour tout
le monde et donc il vient le samedi 22
octobre à 15 heures donc ce sera tout
haut que tout l'occasion de lui poser
des questions et savoir comment on
arrive à vivre et à mettre en place tout
ce régiment d'accord
alors laurent je présente un roman
jeunesse qui fait partie de la rentrée
littéraire jeunesse s'agit de maman aime
danser de didier pobel édité chez bulles
de savon c'est un tout petit éditeur et
je pense que c'est important d'en parler
donc pour cette rentrée littéraire y
propose un très court roman qui
s'adresse plutôt aux adolescents alors
c'est un peu particulier c'est un enfant
qui raconte un évènement tragique qui
est celui des attentats au bataclan mais
comme un petit garçon qui du jour au
lendemain
la suite d'un week-end ne comprends pas
très bien pourquoi il va plus à l'école
pourquoi savamment n'est plus là je vois
son père arrête pas lui dire mais tu
sais ta maman elle aimait beaucoup
d'anciens voilà il va s'interroger
pendant très longtemps sur l'absence de
cette maman pourquoi sa grand-mère
s'enferme et reniflant permanence
offerts là il sent qu'il se passe
quelque chose que son père est trop
qu'alain vous fait re opération à lui
ils ont attrapé des rumeurs voilà ils
ont attrapé des rhumes enfin bon ça il
sent bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
pas mais il est trop petit pour
comprendre et sa grand-mère du nom de
dessiner des méchants fin voilà ils sont
pas il sent bien qu'il ya quelque chose
qui va pas et nous on va le retrouver
dix ans après lors de la commémoration
des 10 ans des attentats du bataclan et
la voilà il arrive à retourner sur cette
histoire c'est assez il a trois quatre
ans quand lors des événements donc il
arrive à se souvenir de ce qui s'est
passé et comment il l'a vécu d'accord ce
qu'il s'en souvienne de ses souvenirs
quoi et de comment on lui a annoncé
c'est ça aussi la question de comment
l'annoncer à un enfant parce que lui
enfin comme à mon avis beaucoup
d'enfants de 3 4 ans le fait que sa mère
soit morte ça doit pas signifier grand
chose pour lui il songe à lui manque
mais il comprend pas la notion de la
mort et qui comprend pas pourquoi son
père est dans cet état et qui sont les
méchants et pourquoi il faut quand la
fin donc oui un joli passage sur ce
cette annonce la durée par camion vers
son enfant
et c1 c'est un beau roman c'est pas gai
du tout hein mais c'est un beau roman
qui met en avant la liberté
l'idée qu'il faut continuer à aller au
concert elle et danser comme ses parents
faisaient
voilà c'est parce qu'ils l'ont pas tué
seulement sa maman mais le concept
qu'ils avaient de ce que c'était que les
soirs les sorties le soir des adultes ça
avait l'air d'être libre voilée lui
forcément il sent que quelque chose a
changé d'accord voilà non m dont la
moyenne danser c'est un beau roman assez
dur donc vraiment plus tôt pour les
adolescents même si le vocabulaire est
un buzz semble d'accord
[Musique]